hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome oh are you to burn
appointment ray no I'm not not here for
an interview either I don't need you at
the moment thank you very much so we got
the codes to a door over here
with this guy who has been mind control
you can't make me do it I don't know
they're trying to make you do oh that
guy does not look okay but I'm hoping
I'm hoping there's gonna be a reason
that I need to go in here six nine six
eight so don't attack me
attack me don't attack me hi my name is
markiplier how are you you okay you all
right buddy do I need to glue you was on
de Vries 7 3 to 400 is not real they
seem to be pretty real if their mind
controlling you uh-huh hi how's it going
oh my god
Oh
okay was I supposed to do that huh huh
what was I supposed to do that was that
something that was supposed to happen or
was that just me being dumb and doing
something I wasn't supposed to be doing
it what the hell was that okay anyway
now that I got that out of the way I
can't I dunno what I gained from that I
got a cold but good night I guess I
couldn't see that from the window now
could I okay so that's the reason I came
in here idea this isn't my fault I feel
like this is my fault
okay de Vries seven three to four so
who's de Vries is the question and how
much longer am I gonna be distracted
from where I owe Hendrik de Vries chief
surgeon okay I don't have his thing but
maybe if I find him
good to see you too carry on there I
guess okay but if I find de Vries right
here he's in the Talos one robbed on
Hani I wasn't trying to harm you but
okay I'm gonna carry on now so he's in
the lobby
oh I know I've been distracted from
everything I'm gonna go up and I'm gonna
salvage this stuff I'm gonna craft some
more stuff and then I'm gonna get on
with this game but I just feel like this
stuff is so important everything that
I'm discovering here is just like it's
supposed to be here it's all part of the
big plan it's all part of everything
here and I've got so many weapons like
jeez I went from having almost nothing
to having almost no room and mice in my
uh my finger I don't even know if I need
this hawk traveler thine old enemy the
knave stands no chance against thee now
okay alright alright now I need that oh
man it's so cool though that I can just
craft through 3d printing whatever I
need so I'm gonna go for more bullets
that's about as many bullets as I can
we make wow it's so good at that
it's so good at that uh I can't make
anything
what am I out of I'm out of an out of
what is that whatever whatever that
material is I don't have enough of it so
I gotta keep moving I don't know where
dr. DeVry is maybe on the map somewhere
it'll show him here he's is that him is
that where he is
it says objective so I'm assuming that's
true it's in the Arboretum but I don't
know how to get to the Arboretum because
I'm pretty sure I'm at the highest place
that I can go so I'm in just i'ma take
this thank you even though I've got a
bag full of Taif and weirdest stuff oh
god it hurt myself damn it
medical attention necessary I heard I
fell I got a boo-boo on my Baba please I
got a little rough day still this will
only take a moment
not a patient experience question I
don't care okay so this time I'm asking
to take the stairs and not try to hurry
my way through this oh yeah that's right
I need to go through the I need to go
through the the up off offices upstairs
here to be able to get where I need to
go the teleconference in room so that's
gonna take me over to dr. Calvin dr.
Calvin dr. Calvino's I was close ooh
hello
what was this was this some sort of
design workshop over here and what were
they designing besides these neural
montz cuz I can't imagine well actually
I can't imagine that this entire complex
would be just about the neural mods
because this kind of technology people
would pay hand-over-fist
if you could learn French just from
jabbing something in your eye
then people would do that but obviously
there's a caveat here of the people
forgetting all their memories up until
that point once the neural mod is
removed now that's bad but maybe is it
that bad maybe someone you can use that
to your advantage like people could
stage things where they forget like if
you're doing something shady uh they put
in a row mod in you
before and then immediately after if you
ever get caught you just take it out and
you never remember anything maybe you do
hello
I gotta give that off my favorite bar
because that has got to go unfavored
please we're gonna unfavorite that bad
boy and we're gonna favorite it no
unfavorite it I don't want it I don't
want it to be in my favorite can this be
in the four slot how do I there we go
okay all right I think I can smash whoa
hi you all right there don't look so
good oh just hope hi oh that hurt me oh
you son of a [ __ ] take parts and
dismantle required well I don't have
dismantle what good is that gonna do me
okay I hope are you doing thanks for the
ran charity got one but I'll take it
ooh a lot of food over here hello
sparkling wine emails
hey I sent Larson to the demo theater to
see if he can sneak a bottle of old
Sardar join us join us I don't know demo
delay just a heads up the art acts
propulsion system demo will have to be
delayed we're still working on a slight
calibration issue in the machine shop
but it's nothing to worry about okay I
have no idea what that is so I'm not
particularly worried about anything
gonna hack this nah level two well I'm
gonna have level to hacking pretty soon
here soon as I get more neural mods
because it seemed to be able to get a
lot of those I mean not a lot of those
but if I can ever get to the point where
I can craft him again that's gonna be a
lot better for ya okay nothing over here
I know I saw another one of those things
and now I know they blow up in my face
after I'd beat the shroud out of him I
hear him oh I hear too far too fast to
and Johnson's term came to an end paving
the way for President Reagan even then
the space race was showing signs of
faltering the eager push from previous
decades being dulled by the lack of
advancement that space had seemed to
promise the Soviet Union had already
suffered economic collapse through
similar space focus many in Washington
and the Pentagon found further spending
on the space program
popular giving rise to a wave of
politician many of whom had also
successfully prevented u.s. involvement
in Vietnam that focused on solving
problems at home ah yes oh boy so long
farewell alrighty then oh can I lit oh
can i oh I can see hi Oh how's it going
out there lonely I imagine the space
elevator terraforming Mars but the cost
of these Mars installations and their
continued maintenance is staggering and
their Spartan shells are a far cry from
the idyllic colonies pictured by the
turn of the center century inspirational
space tourism posters all that might be
about to change in a rare interview
Transtar president Alex u reveals his
vision of a Mars where families in short
sleeves can picnic in a grassy field
then pick out the point of light that
it's earth after the Sun sets enabling
this vision requires terraforming Mars
the most challenging engineering problem
the human race has ever faced you
presents an innocuous grey Moss to me an
extremal file organism designed
specifically for that purpose dubbed
takaki a Katherine the simple looking
plant is actually a fantastically
efficient organic machine that given
enough centuries will convert the
Martian atmosphere into something that
very much resembles our own well that's
all well and good but I think we got to
deal with all the the other horrible
monstrosity that are currently wreaking
havoc on our systems right here on this
table got you but a clue you
oh that got you good well apparently one
of those explosive canisters is enough
to blast him into next century
alrighty then security I'm gonna try to
get in the security officer hi who's
losing their mind why would a phantom be
saying they're losing in their mind
unless they are another person by
indifferent Ori full I just I just
I'm just got eat everything glug glug
glug that's taking up so much space in
my inventory ooh yes please
my prize [ __ ] just taking the ammo for
that but I'll take what I can get hello
oh we got a lot of personnel down here
yeah I can make 9-millimeter which I
think I could already do okay hurry map
download add security controls hi hello
alright security controls unlock
security locker oh hey okay is that over
there yeah one second alright anything
good in here
hello hello really just spare parts oh
oh oh this is incredibly useful I've got
a freaking turret uh here we go blam oh
my god I've got my own turret oh that's
awesome
oh that's so cool what can I do with it
oh I can't go through here oh hi you
know what up enough let's set this up
right here hey hi how are you doing you
good thank you
you could look for the key card but
there are probably other ways in are
there'd always been good at improvising
okay that's me what you'll do I think I
know but well
oh thanks for that cryptic message there
oh boy oh boy more booze good is that
gonna do me good oh wait whoa whoa hi
how are you doing oh that is go-go
fattiest go oh oh I climb hello
fatty is almost made it out of there he
got blasted okay do it do I need to go
down there okay let me gather up all the
[ __ ] around here oh hi they didn't
notice you keycard employee entrance old
Sardar oh this is the guy that just was
going on a date oh now he's dead oh
that's sad and Clive is still down there
so I'm guessing this is the alternate
way in hello oh hello can i glue that
and glue that can i that's what it's
originally meant for right oh yeah that
did that real good
thanks for the glue probably don't wanna
bash that on there okay hello oh god
damn it I'm full again oh I've gotten
out of the wrench I don't need these
wrenches uh I don't need this food
either I don't need the booze I've got
on me either I need a quick save more
often let me take care of that real
quick by drinking it up oh and I've got
these upgrade things I forgot about that
let me upgrade the rest of this um let's
do accuracy that's always a good thing
um magazine capacity why not a guess
range Anna let's upgrade good
old-fashioned shout gun here two more
firepower oh hell yeah oh hell yeah
that freed up some space now let's get
drunk as a skunk off old hard are here
wait no this this this is it drinking
drinking drinking
this probably good for me and that Alou
you get so we got that take that that
that that I don't need another wrench
whoa I am like I am I'm [ __ ] up pretty
much I'm pretty [ __ ] up hi I'm up here
now it's my favorite thing to do
climbing the oh my turrets on the other
side of that door I can make it over
there and open that door oh I'm so drunk
sorry douche Oh
booze key firehouse requests gonna get
him Oh what hey that was shockingly
effective cool all right so I got a whoa
what did I just get a recycler charge
what the hell is that
when detonated the recycler charge
breaks down the molecular structure of
nearby objects into recyclable material
your uniform offers some degree of
protection but it's not failsafe
standing too close can provide proof
hazardous I can be broken down into
recyclables oh the future is so advanced
they've managed to weaponize recycling
that's so efficient uh-oh
alrighty then
uh hello over here oh hello over there
I'm gonna glue you I got plenty of glue
my glue is extremely efficient don't you
know hello bluh bluh bluh bluh
give me that more okay the man there's
something over here that I need
ballistics lab ooh that sounds good loop
that oh hello alrighty then I got a key
card to the ballistics lab which was
easy enough to get I'm sure is glad when
they put the things that I need right
next to the things that I want oh I see
how he's gonna go oh hi there hi how's
it going
am I gonna be able to drop a recycler in
there oh they're gonna show me how this
works I bet they are I bet they are
I've been they are okay requirements
chamber sealed recycler and EMP grenade
in the container okay uh I need
something in the container so open
container open chamber no not that not
that chamber no no no no not that one
that's that's not the one I wanted no I
wanted the grenade jammer why would you
call that's a container ah
oh well did it just die
no it did not just die they're coming
for me now oh you [ __ ] I thought I
had that how do I hopefully open this
thing
hello e hey all right you're gonna get
laughed because Frick you all right fine
then you guys are laughing at me but
this is not fair that's not my fault
I was gonna have a really cool moment
there and then it's I thought I thought
I thought I thought it was I thought it
was I thought that man I thought and how
else are you supposed to do it there's
no use here was I supposed to things not
my fault
I fine whatever all open the goddamn
container and then I'll throw my god
damn dude whatever a recycler charge in
there looking cool oh wow fine
whoa where did you go what hello why are
you down there
no that's okay all right then you know
what I don't know what to think anymore
Oscar yeah I must assume that guy I
don't know I don't know man
what to think anymore that was supposed
to be a really cool demonstration where
I do real good stuff and yet here I
stand at the precipice of destruction
Lilly I was testing the recycler charge
of something peculiar happened that
place in the usual source material into
the chamber instead of the charge mixed
in with the result was something I've
never seen before
a purple almost organic looking
substance may be something contaminated
the source material I'm unsure how to
proceed since I've placed the
unidentified material in the safe for
now
so that was a mimic Lily I've been
afford you're in need of an updated
recycler charge fabrication plan it just
so happens I have a spare plan to my
quarters remind me next shift I'll bring
it down
um is it safe over here with level one
hacking I can do this oh I can do this
oh [ __ ] ass mind go faster here we go
and see you got it
hacking successful who know it was so
easy what have we got in here
whoa oh I thought that was 46 material
what a bunch of baloney what a bunch of
malarkey all right so that's
what how much is exploding around here
why is everything exploding there is no
need for that okay I got all the
material here I think I can go now now
that I've thoroughly embarrassed myself
okay breach over there can't go through
there [ __ ] dude and this place is just
going to Garbo going to Garbo fast I
must be losing my mind who said that who
said that okay so I need to get through
there I gotta oh I can does this work on
that oh it does a whole [ __ ] alright
then
well that was easy enough let me take my
turret with me wherever I put it oh it's
right here
nobody Boop come with me I have a funny
feeling I'm gonna need you in the next
room
anybody want a face full of turn Oh
deploy damn Boy Scout yeah scan away
buddy there's a lot of things to scan in
here hi
why
that's just silly
Oh No oh that poor guy he blued how he
blue doll over what a poor guy I know
there's mimicks around here I know for a
fact there are many a mimic hither and
thither oh where does it still all
righty then
Oh take it oh oh I don't have enough
space for that but I can carry this poop
oh I can walk right through it
apparently well that oh I could have
just gone that way in there I didn't
know that
oh I didn't know there was gonna be a
super-secret way all right fine then
that would have been a lot easier than
using my glue on the electricity there
Oh
oh boy there's two turrets here Shepard
well that one seems to be doing okay so
I'm gonna leave that lie I'm gonna bring
this one just up a little bit come here
you
can I set you on this thing not what I
wanted go oh boy
what do you mean not enough space
deploying the point
what kill it kill it kill it kill it
kill it kill please you kidding me kill
the damn thing my suit is gone kill it
ah
oh yes oh my god jeezum challenge
[ __ ] killing it you got it pieces of
[ __ ] oh my god you [ __ ] [ __ ] ah my
turret strat didn't work
who defunct it man who know would even a
thunka did it what were you doing you
stupid douche how did my guy blow why
are you going over there [ __ ] you over
there what happened to you I don't even
know oh no all right whatever now that
we've gotten to that part this is over
here
woo operator just been so cool what kind
of operator something that can help me
in combat maybe that'd be awfully nice
engineering oh thank you man operators
are the best when they're not trying to
kill me Dad holy [ __ ] dude
thank you okay now that I did that I can
finally maneuver my way through here Oh
oh [ __ ] hang on wait Wow why did I need
a wrench fabrication plan there was no
reason for that
there was no reason at all why did I get
radiation for that oh well have no there
we go got it nailed it I'm the best
right what do they have here whoo
spare parts can't take that no mods yes
how many do I have now oooh
weapon upgrade kit holy [ __ ] I'm getting
so many weapon upgrades Clive we need to
up the reload speed on the glue cannon
the actuators are slow on this thing hey
when it comes to glue gun viscosity you
gotta take it nice and steady
you got to take it slow
hey [ __ ] [ __ ] you where did you come
from what does that mean the [ __ ] did
you come from where did you go wait a
minute
were there to stand clear ones I see you
what you doing
not today okay I can't carry that I
gotta go to a recycler at some point
here hello uh damn it look alive
freaking don't what the hell did you
just die from oh my turret I forgot I
had that guy setup I don't know where
the there guy liquefied the corpse there
for a second there um where do I go what
do I do
this looks important hello Bob rate use
terminal every airlock has a manual seal
you'll have to disengage before you can
spacewalk uh-huh mile engineered is a
safety measure it's
yeah I kind of agree on that one I
wouldn't stray oh geez
other airlocks you find will have to be
open from the inside first
no last thing ah of course I don't
okay so I need to find a propulsion
system where is a roll what's up there
hello
I like climbing on things you tell me
why I'm climbing this one though huh
whoa where am i oh oh
someone had fun up here it's sad knowing
that they're all dead oh man this is my
gluer sis this is someone else's glue
who's been gluing up this area alrighty
then so I can go over there al that's
gonna hurt ah whoa somehow I'm okay huh
uh I just uh I think I can do this oh no
come on come on oh you bastards you know
you want to get me up there
come on maybe if I actually did it on
the wall that'd be a little better there
we go that's how you do it I now know
how to climb get our tax compulsion
system organic material a whole bunch of
this carbo and a frickin recycler which
is gonna be exactly what I need and I
need to get rid of this wrench this gun
need to be careful about this because if
I could toss anything I don't need that
I'm gonna be in long trouble what are
these four psychostimulant that
increases the psychic potential of an
individual when injected restores 60
psycho points I don't know what that is
I don't have that
do I need that don't I probably need
that I definitely need that in the
future but I'm just asking if I need it
right now
which I'm gonna say yes I'm gonna say
yes I'm gonna say I need that
that makes it easy well holy [ __ ] that
was like the easiest objective I've ever
had I sure do love the fact that they're
putting what I need right next to me all
the time but that's just another reason
that I need to go out and I need to
actually explore because there's a whole
bunch of other stuff here platform why
why is that important haha okay I got
EMP charges and Franklin Goods who was
that
okay I'm not done over here though I
guess all right then
man there's a lot of different things
that I need to get here just oh man
there's so many materials my warning
radiation as I'm sure you've noticed oh
yeah that radiation area assassin Lee
Gary snow here I work in ku services I
heard that some scuttlebutt about a new
dart gun you guys worked up possibly
something about an assassin style game
in the Arboretum and crew quarters I
want in thanks Gary okay all right then
oh man that's sad they're all dead
they're all dead now
hmm oh okay so I don't man I'm really
running out of that iron looking stuff
so I don't want to use too much of that
I think I'm good on supplies right now
cuz I got a decent amount of bullets
I've got shotgun shells
I've got crossbow bullets and I got
grenades and a lot of glue I am just
full to the eyeballs with my patented
market glue I'll never ever speak those
words ever again in my goddamn life why
I regret everything about all of my
choices up to this point in my life all
right but there were other substances
that I can get so I'm just gonna get
everything so that I can recycle it real
quick before I go outside on my
spacewalk which is going to be flippin
awesome I can't wait for that
like I love space and I know I hope I'm
gonna be able to go out and be cool like
everybody else okay guys I think it's
ready now I've dubbed it the hunters
pole caster okay so they're talking
about the bolter let's see have you
looked into the operator dispenser logs
and missing parts every operator on the
station needs to be accounted for I'll
bring it up with Alex next please do is
not my responsibility it's Morgan's
let's see um
dr. sorenstein I checked with the neuro
mod stamps in the lattices and the
fabricators and both check out there's
no obvious failure in the components I
may need to disassemble the machine it's
possible there's something in the specs
egg WA is using Vic's causing the
failure ring hard to believe it goes I
don't know how to process a name pretty
thorough but we all make mistakes I'll
keep working on maybe there was
something specific about that batch
weren't there are a few scrambled ones
last cycle - I have no idea what they're
talking about them but there must have
been something wrong
with the knurl mod fabrication which
leads me to believe that something
beyond everyone's understanding is
happening with these neural mods which
is what was said what Morgan or Morgan
me quote unquote was saying about this
whole thing they were trying to make a
new one based on the Typhoon's oh I
never started this in the first place
oh okay Shepherd a baboon come here came
back here oh hell yeah is that what I
need the mineral material oh it is the
mineral material okay so I'm gonna make
another one of these crap that sweet
okay I'm gonna craft
I need more glue yes no nah but I do
need one of these I'll take a medkit
infinite licenses on that bad boy John
take another one of those I mean why not
if I ever get in trouble I'm gonna need
make sure that I need as many med kits
as it possibly can
blue canister might as well make another
one I can do it and then I'm gonna hold
off from there because I think I think I
want to make sure that I have more and
more of the supplies on hand before I
actually get in any trouble here so
let's now go outside we've already
unlocked it so it's saved and then show
me bus key we're going outside it's
probably just gonna be like a platform
that I walk across but I've got a
propulsion system so I'm assuming
there's gonna be some flying going on
here and I also like like everything
looks moderately steampunk here for the
year 2032 things look a little bit hello
hi microgravity
here's Transtar suit is equipped with a
propulsion system navigate the harsh
environment of space navigating 0d use
the Oise to thrust and shift to boost
thrust press Q need a break ah
you can press space to ascend C descend
or hold Q and E to roll Oh press Q plus
E to break okay well that doesn't make a
lot of sense but I'm gonna try my best
here what
oh yeah oh that works nicely oh my god
oh oh oh it's beautiful
oh it's beautiful oh the moon can I go
to the moon what would happen if I just
flew all the way to the moon I would
smash into the surface and die oh isn't
that too bloody oh my god it's so
beautiful oh I got a break before I go
anywhere okay so what do we got here
hull breach hardware labs whoa well this
thing is flip dick and huge oh and a
little ostentatious don't you think and
what are with the revolving panels oh
man
ah so weird it's like encircled by these
panels are they meant to catch space
debris or something or are they solar
panels but it looks like there are solar
panels all across the entire surface
which is cool and makes a lot of sense
but man this is so cool
human corpse oh is that that are these
the corpses that I saw oh no oh no oh so
cool the Arboretum is where that's where
de Vries Devery to free oh oh yeah I'm
sorry I'm just tickled to death by this
I'm booshed baby oh yeah oh that's some
good boost I'm redlining my my speed ahh
brakes okay hello how are you doing
I saw you be shot out here oh not well I
see oh but I'm just gonna take these
things thank you
there was another corpse over here that
I saw you know you know me it's got to
find all the corpses
man is that the one or is there another
one over multiple objectives over there
I'm gonna try to find the corpse and and
of course I'm gonna explore a little bit
so all those are logged so I don't think
I can go to those bah I'm fairly certain
that I should be able to navigate my way
over here unless Oh what are you can i
okay hi there hi you look bad can i glue
you like glue you please tell me oh
that's not working that's not work I'm
not working oh this was a mistake
oh this was a mistake okay go go go go
go go go go I'm gonna consume a medkit
once I know I'm okay where's that
goddamn corpse oh boy
poor boy it's over there why is it over
there I was just over there oh yeah
space is dangerous all right I'm gonna
find you eventually did I miss something
here god damn I have no idea where I am
and where I've been I get all turned
around oh there we go that's what I'm
looking for hello oh hi hello there how
are you my name is markiplier are you
friendly engineer please fix my suit no
come back go back please mmm thank you I
need that oh okay now I'm gonna take a
medkit because do you have an extra med
kit on you you have a banana peel Jose
Jose you've betrayed me hos I mean
you're dead so I guess yeah what do you
care but you betrayed me oh man
hilarious
oh wait there's another human corpse
over here let's go find out what it is
let's go see I'll heal when I'm dead oh
there's another one oh my god this place
is just littered with corpses how do I
get over to this one we hang on we'll go
over this way I think I got to go around
the outside
oh my god that's so weird ah I get so
topsy-turvy instantaneously are zalman
ago hit this one first and go to that
one oh man oh hi okay that's bad this is
down there it's down there isn't it oh
oh uh uh bing bang quickly go now can I
go in here now please hurry up now oh my
god hurry hurry I'm dying I'm dying I'm
dying oh my god is that a gun oh my god
is that a gun not enough space not a
space the hell do you mean by that not
enough space it's just that everything
is not organized enough for enough space
Auto sort the take it there we go tea
somes okay I need to make I need to eat
that number one and then I need to take
this Medicaid and that's all I'm gonna
do for now because if I die out here I
want to retry this I'm not gonna die
that easy well so I got a new gun oh the
Q beam oh my god what is that okay I get
it it's now the time for that okay oh
please go now
woo hi oh my God where are you oh my god
oh geez I'm out of ammo for this one
[ __ ] doctor okay you know what I'm not
gonna
no he'll be where's that goddamn corpse
there you are I'm going to you I'm going
to you I am gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
gonna get the fudge out here's what I'm
gonna do
that's a wall okay oh my god why you
suck so hard why did I do this this is a
mistake no gonna make it no no no you
let me take it Sean don't don't do it
don't do it don't do it don't do it
don't do it don't do it don't just get
glued oh my god you're huge oh my god
you're so huge
well jeez you so huge what do you have
anything were you worth it
I don't think so oh this was a mistake
Oh God everything is horrible what did
they come out here I was not prepared
for that I was not prepared I am still
alive by some goddamn miracle but I was
not prepared for that holy [ __ ] space is
a dangerous place nobody should be there
everybody should stand ORS freak that
I'm gonna go to space till the end of my
days
which will probably be the day that I go
to space okay getting the hang of this
flying zero G's thing it is a bit rough
and tumbly but here we go
hello oh oh this is so dead space I just
got a million dead space vibes oh it's
so cool aw he's so cool
ignore what I said about how everything
was horrible and never go to space go to
space immediately god this is our future
it has to be oh can i hack that look I
don't know error key code I don't think
that's even possible unless there's some
way to seal this and get gravity back in
here I don't think that's gonna work
are you hell yeah shotgun shells I
haven't even seen more ammo with that
whoa okay um oh hi ho hi how are you
doing there I'll be with you in a second
mr. mysterious ballet man getting all
the spare parts for whatever the hell
the spare parts are for I think they're
for repairs and whatnot but hi how you
doing good thank you for the neural mods
I think I won't be infrared at all okay
to finish this array I fabricated a
shit-ton a glass Hey I don't recall you
asked me to set up a new array you must
have misunderstood but are you honestly
I prefer if you left my experiments
alone in my absence
well seriously I would not mean all no
of course
let's just for the time being the ia it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter let's
talk about it tomorrow huh
so Lorenzo wasn't doing too well huh
well I suppose you've turned or you're
ignoring me
I just want to well I will be a little
late for my shift tomorrow but them the
first thing in the morning I want you to
put together a new micro lens array you
see that old one is it's garbage
they get what you need from the machine
shop and in Clive is being an ass just
take it from the supply closet when he's
not going we're not supposed to know the
cold but well I'm sending it to anyway
okay I might have already broken into
that thing but I have no idea okay so I
I'm a little lost as to what I why did I
go out there again I have no idea I
can't even remember why I went out there
in the first place all I knew that I was
gonna get an the propulsion system and
then who told me to go outside why did
he tell me to go outside again did I
need to get something there was I
supposed to get that gun was I supposed
to fight through those horrible things
cuz those things were way beyond what I
was ready to take on I mean I'll go back
out there I'll be a brave I'll be a
brave boy if you need me to be a brave
boy but for right now I feel like I
didn't need to do something doctor
Calvino's workshop was I supposed to go
to that I'm blanking on so many things
because oh hey cuz my brain is still all
about like all about what's been
happening thus far okay what does it
look like the shape in the glass who's
talking to me
who the hell is talking oh oh this is
where oh this is where that thing is
Calvin oh [ __ ] is Calvin still down
there Calvin oh man thanks for the neuro
mater guess oh he's down there alright
okay so zero let's try to be stealthy
about this got my shout gown
whoa were you at oh yes cannisters
hello which way you going there buddy
trip
oh come on walk through the fire walk
through the fire baby through the I
wasn't ready for that a little more than
my paygrade
shucks holy [ __ ] that guy hit me quick
man those guys are no joke I the little
mimics I can handle now but those big
guys they are no joke I gotta take them
a little more carefully cuz man they
messed me up instantaneously I also got
to pay more attention to my environment
and try to use more of the more the
tools at my disposal because if I can
use those correctly than I'm gonna be a
little better off come on
that's right there that's right there
Wyatt John you made me look bad all
right fine then you want to be like that
be like that whoa what is that increases
your movement speed while sneaking hey
that's good okay
I don't sneak enough but I just said
that I needed to you I don't use that
inner ooh I like that I like that very
much
oh and also I have seven neural mods I
gotta use those okay I could get hacking
too or I could get repair to dismantle
oh that means when I fight robots I'll
be able to get more spare parts but do I
need the spare parts really I've got a
backlog of like huge backlog do I could
get the better recycling that is always
good leverage to gunsmith oh these are
all options hmm oh these are all good
options mmm one of these toughness
combat focus stealth that's always a
good one since I just got the stealth
mod I'm gonna go for the stealth because
Oh do 200% damage enemies well they're
on the way of you uh all walk and run
without making noise all that so
stealthy well it's a stealthy that's so
stealthy wait well that's hardly any
different if you're already doing 200%
damage then why would you need to do two
hundred and fifty percent damage it's
like the same thing at that point no but
I could go for I'm gonna go for the
sneak attack because I like doing the
stealth route in games I like doing the
real sneaky stuff especially in games
like this cuz this reminds me of what
deus ex was like cuz this is that's the
game it's like a mixture of Deus Ex a
mixture of Bioshock and a mixture of
dead space all wrapped in one and I love
it it's just really really cool and
captivating what it's got going on here
and there's so many these hunters bolt
casters down here and all of random
[ __ ] can I have that I'm full up for
oh hi well that's convenient well thank
you I was just talking about how I was
full up I am let me get a big old
transfer thing going on here burnt-out
disk any you get can you get goddamn
there we go get the goddamn gobbed up
organic material okay let's put more in
here then we're gonna dump this we're
gonna man I have so many weapons that's
my problem right now is I have so many
weapons maybe next time I should try to
get the skill who's gonna increase my
inventory because that's that's really
what's slowing me down at this point ooh
mmm I like that but I'm gonna hold on to
that because I don't know what to do
oh I also need to grab the weapon mod
how do I need to grab the weapon mod
that I forgot to get uh there's so much
stuff that I just overlooked with my
inventories full so also this guy all
this poor guy man he was so close he was
so close where are you machine shop I
was just I heard an explosion forget
that grab whatever you can and get to my
office what are you a QA ting what what
should I do romance exotic material just
hurry be in my office
yes sir bring a glue gun alright well
that didn't do him a lot of good is glue
gun only got him so far he's not an
expert glue gun er like myself alright
also what am I doing with the flex is
foam bolts do I even need this I mean if
I don't need it I can always make it
again in the future
right I can always make this again I
don't necessarily need need it I will
also get a spare part out of it if i
dismantle it which again I don't know
universal components cleaners and
adhesives used to make repairs I've got
super pair kits I've got a whole bunch
of stuff I'm just gonna keep moving and
also I'm gonna take oh god they're med
kit I'm gonna go back up I'm gonna get
the weapon upgrade mod I'm gonna use it
on either my shotgun or something else
and then I'm gonna keep moving because I
got to get going
I'm running behind ooh or I can go in
here
okay well that's seemed bad oh this is
where I can go through the looking-glass
stuff ah can I move this yeah
husky yeah husky whoo I need you please
yes yes thank you very much
cuz I'm taking a lot of damage lately
cuz I had a ton of those things and then
I went out to space which was a big-ass
mistake what are you what are you you're
like little bats Oh what are you oh so
cool oh so cool all right so we got that
we get this nothing over here over here
anything behind here no oh my god it's
transparent on one side and just a
freakin portal in another world on the
other side what is fascinating oh this
is fascinating I'm so in love with this
this is sci-fi - such a cool degree also
Oh whiteboards heard me Bob I don't
trust whiteboards just don't trust him I
just don't trust him don't trust
all right so anything else over here I
know there's the main objective thing up
there but I'm scanning for goodies
there's a Miette metaphor here you know
typically the objective of control
theory is to monitor the output of a
system and compared to the desired
output the reference signal the
difference between the actual and the
desired outputs the error signal is
applied as feedback to the input of the
system to bring the actual output closer
to the reference good control systems
and good engineers learn from the past
you're trying to tell me something here
you're trying to tell me to learn from
my past here you're trying to you're
trying to be all metaphorical about it
okay dr. Calvino oh we Mary this is dr.
Calvin or require you to fabricate a
travel mug that weighs exactly 170 grams
empty of course my feeble hands need a
lightweight container for my coffee I'll
be sure to put it in a good word doctor
Thorstein for your assistance dr. Calvin
oh okay I'll get right on that huh
that's weird Clive this is dr. Calvino I
need you to modify a scale so when it
reads 170 grams it sends an on-off
signal please let me know when it's
ready sure
okay I see what's going on here Lorenzo
I had a look at the specs you sent me I
see a few pop problems I just didn't
realize you've offloaded so much of the
processing and storage what if someone
took a wrench to the main server the
whole system goes down anyway come by
when you get a chance we'll go over the
details I have a few suggestions if
you're amenable uragan so there's a
scale here there's a scale here that
apparently when it reads exactly 170
grams and I don't know where the scale
is but that's probably a little easter
egg spell hint here when I read oh is
this the scale well I don't know how to
puzzle catch can't seem to tell you what
did that work is Ellen that was is this
the scale no that's not the scale what's
the problem here what seems to be the
pro well just as simple as that
you got a push button and then it's on I
guess oh hi
okay then ooh video playback Network
utilities verify and restore server
connection diagnostic diagnose network
screens uh disconnected okay looking
grass screens all screens intact okay is
there good ah okay hey I did something
the looking glass screens are online
again yeah back to your office as soon
as you can
it's important you hear the rest of your
mess okay again may lead you there
I uh I kind of goofed a bit I got a goof
to bed I destroyed my glass I didn't
mean to do that I didn't mean to do that
but I did that so what are you gonna do
about that be the way that's all the
time I got for this episode this is such
a cool game I I know I'm hesitant to get
excited immediately and call a game
great but I am loving this game I'm
loving it it's so intricate it's
challenging it is a little annoying with
going back and forth with spare parts
but I'm so into this I'm so into the
story of it I'm like so into it oh I
want more
but either way thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of this down the comments below
and let me know what you think how I'm
doing if I'm flailing like an idiot or
if I'm on the right track here so thanks
again and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
[Music]